the ingram angle town hall from orlando
florida and the american comeback
in florida not only are we going to want
to protect the law enforcement and all
the jobs we're actually actively working
to recruit out of state law enforcement
because we do have needs in our police
and our sheriff's departments nypd
minneapolis seattle if you're not being
treated well
we'll treat you better here you can fill
important needs for us
now that was last october
sensing you know the low morale lack of
support the democrat-run cities and
states were obviously giving these
officers to risk it all every day
and governor desantis began a program
that was you know trying to bring
officers to the sunshine state and
despite the fact that five thousand
dollar bonuses don't even take effect
until july first of this year
some officers just couldn't wait that
includes my next guess here now are
kelsey and william ardis nypd transfers
now brevard county florida sheriff
deputies great to see both of you
now
kelsey we were just chit-chatting
because i used to live in new york and
so i'm chit-chatting where you guys are
from so you didn't even wait for the
bonus you had to get the heck out of uh
you know i'd say dodge but in your case
queens yes we were very eager to come to
florida to be in a state led by governor
desantis and work for sheriff ivy and
brevard county now
when you saw what happened during the
riots after um the killing of george
floyd
as someone who lived in new york
my heart my heart broke for the people
of new york
good officers people trying to keep
peace on the ground
william
as a police officer at the time you're
getting stuff chucked at you in the
streets
what what went through your mind
the main thing that went through my mind
was
i got to get home at the end of the day
get home to my family my wife
and you know just worrying you know
where i'm gonna be
you know where we were going to get sent
to but
for the most part it was
i got to go home at the end of the day
just like everybody else you have to
survive and it's all you but you knew
being a police officer kelsey was going
to be dangerous yes and that's the
nature of the job
but explain what was happening on the
streets during the reign of democrat
terror uh in the uh in manhattan in the
boroughs at the time that you were most
concerned
it just became a very date it was a
dangerous job that was already becoming
more dangerous for us
and it was scary um
we didn't see each other for days
and it was just you were there to
basically protect the people that were
you know shouting you know harm to law
enforcement at you when it was very
scary
and william what do you say to officers
across the country who are feeling the
way you felt you know just some months
back
i'll tell them the same thing somebody
else told me
florida's a great place to work you got
a great governor
sheriff ivey he's fantastic he cares
about his department everybody in it
i would i would say come to florida
now governor speaking of law and order
um
click orlando just did a story today
about
an ice office just miles away from here
where at least 250 people now are camped
outside this orlando ice office waiting
to be seen i guess they have to register
after they've crossed the border
illegally and they said they were from
haiti cuba venezuela colombia
and the businesses in the area i mean
they feel terrible for people who are
out in the sun and they're sleeping in
tents on the street
but this is because our border our
southern border is not being enforced in
florida and also down in miramar office
the ice office i'm hearing reports that
it's a nightmare down there for people
how are you going to deal with this in
the streets of this county well we when
i had people down at the border last
summer the people they were interdicting
a lot of them were saying they wanted to
come to florida like i was being
criticized you're not a border state why
are you doing this because it affects
everybody the fentanyl that's coming
across the the border is affecting every
state in this union that's why the
number one cause of death for 18 to 45
is now fentanyl overdoses we have money
in the state budget i don't have it yet
i'm going to get it within the next few
weeks if biden is caravaning people into
florida they obviously are well no i
think i think what you're seeing there
is these are people that are getting
here on their own
which is harder to do if there's a big
movement of them then you can stop at
the at the interstate and then you can
reroute we want to reroute to delaware
we think that that's appropriate to be
able to do that's what we're going to do
well you will you go after employers who
are knowingly hiring illegal aliens who
are coming in yeah so we we have done
that so there have been people that
there were people dropped off a couple
months ago we went after it turns out
they had h2a agriculture
visas and so we checked it out so we do
follow that and employers need to know
you need to hire legal workers yeah that
situation down in that ice office both
ice offices untenable kelsey kelsey and
william great to see both of you and we
hope you have a great career here in
florida more with governor desantis next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else